i'm lucy james reading for reviewer
james carr
i love two types of sci-fi stories the
ones that are very dark and heavy with
themes about humanity's failures
and the ones that are corny and feel
like the product of someone who thinks
space
is a playground for fun destroy all
humans is firmly in the second category
embracing its cheesy story and dialogue
it creates an
entertaining sandbox for destruction
that's still relatively satisfying 15
years after its first release
even if it's bogged down by poor audio
quality and shallow stealth mechanics
yeah yeah yeah town's doing great
business is booming hope is on the way
yadda yadda
let's uh barrel through this puppy so i
can get down to the real business of
governing
making time with the delicious miss
rockwell the story plays out as a b
grade sci-fi movie set in the late 50s
early 60s
over the six hours of campaign missions
you'll laugh or groan
at the majority of jokes and bad
one-liners making for an
overall enjoyable experience the premise
of two aliens completely taking over
america because humans are wildly
incompetent
is too ridiculous to take seriously and
the game embraces the absurdity well
the voice work from the original release
helps up the camp level
but the reused dialogue raises a few
issues
the audio quality is flat out bad by
modern standards
its low fidelity really sticks out when
paired with the updated graphics
the characters don't have that many
lines either resulting in annoying
repetition
very early on be prepared to hear about
communists
hundreds of times before you're done you
want to know what's been going on around
here
i'll tell you what's been going on
around here communism that's what
[Applause]
the game's main campaign is split into
missions across six maps
although one of them turnip seed farms
is only used for the tutorial campaign
missions consist of two types of
gameplay stealth and action
the stealth sections are fairly one note
with you taking on a human disguise that
needs to be
occasionally refueled by brain zapping
more humans
additional obstacles like emp devices
and majestic agents
force you to avoid staying in their
range for too long but don't provide
much more challenge beyond zigzagging to
your objective
the rest of the main missions involve
going loud and
well destroying all humans
it has a blast that destroys everything
try it out on the commercial buildings
crypto is armed with four weapons and
psychokinesis
which allows you to zap disintegrate
probe and
throw people and vehicles a satisfying
traversal ability called skate lets you
glide around the world and it feels very
fluid it allows you to go into a
skateboard type movement after dashing
letting you move quickly around the
environment with precise steering
you can easily make quick turns and jump
over objects while continuing to glide
the third person shooting automatically
locks onto enemies allowing you to
dynamically move and fire
smoothly dodging into cover or out of
the way of missiles between
each shot all of the weapons have
varying ammo capacities and damage
levels and the weapon wheel allows for
easy switching
so utilizing all of your tools during a
firefight feels natural
as more powerful enemies are introduced
you also begin to unlock more abilities
and upgrades which ensure you remain
more powerful than the humans
but not to the point of being
overpowered the enemies shout silly
lines about being burned or attacked and
vehicles always explode when defeated
embracing the power of fantasy as you
cause more destruction your notoriety
increases leading to larger and more
powerful responses from the humans
causing mayhem and destruction is
incredibly fun and when the game is at
its best
in other missions you're instead in
crypto's saucer its weapons lack the
variety of crypto's own arsenal
but wrecking a town's worth of buildings
still feels great
not only do some of the weapons produce
fiery leftovers but the buildings
explode into tons of pieces
which is satisfying every time
ah you scattered them like roaches
marvelous there's a lack of variety in
the human enemies though who are limited
to police officers
soldiers majestic agents and mutated
majestic agents
the vehicles run into a similar issue
with the only offensive vehicles being
tanks and robot mechs
which like the human enemies rely
primarily on guns
there are a fairly limited number of
character models in the game and as a
result it makes the otherwise enjoyable
combat
encounters feel repetitive the campaign
missions also feel
disconnected most of them abruptly end
when the objective is met
even if you're in the middle of a
firefight not every mission ends in a
cut scene either so you may simply get
kicked back to the mission select which
is
jarring each campaign mission has
anywhere from one to four optional
objectives
which can involve not getting detected
killing enemies in a certain way or
destroying specific vehicles
these optional objectives add an extra
twist to the combat encounters and if
missed can easily be replayed
however most campaign missions aren't
unique enough from the rest of the game
to warrant a second run through the game
has three boss fights two of which are
back to back at the end of the campaign
these bosses go against the game's ethos
of overpowered carnage seen in the rest
of the game
each boss has a large health bar that
needs to be drained three times to be
defeated
and they take a while to get through
none of the fights are particularly
challenging either each boss only has a
handful of attacks
all of which are heavily telegraphed and
easily dodgeable which makes these
encounters tedious more than anything
destroy all humans certainly shows its
age in places the stealth missions are
rudimentary the boss fights are tedious
and some poor audio work won't let you
forget that this is a game from
15 years ago however its core loop of
causing destruction and mayhem
laying waste to cities and humans still
feels satisfying
destroy all humans often feels like the
ps2 game it is but a fresh coat of paint
and updated controls
definitely make this remake enjoyable to
play through today
[Music]
die pee praying
hey where's that what did you do with my
clip
monkey boy phew
so much for wholesale carnage i guess
i'll just have to settle for ripping
your limbs off one by one
with my bare hands until i find it
with my bare hands